present our work on the Ukraine facility
to you and to the commission we had a
joint committee of the meeting of affet
and Budge and we saw broad consensus in
the vote that has been the case since
the start of the appalling war of
aggression uh that you Russia launched
on Ukraine we have a clear um political
message that has been sent uh we are
clearly standing shoulder by shoulder
with Ukraine and that's a clear message
to Our member states and to the Agger we
will stand by Ukraine during the war
during
Reconstruction and as they prepare to
join the European Union Mr Putin Ukraine
will never return to the gags I would
like to thank my co- rapporter Ida guia
saal Ruel representing the committee on
budgets and i' like to thank her for the
excellent
cooperation and constructive cooperation
that facilitated discussions I'd also
like to thank the shadow reporters in
the two
committees I'd like to thank them for
all their contributions and commitments
we worked under time pressure we want to
get this regulation sealed by the end of
the year we need this debate today and a
vote tomorrow and that wouldn't have
been possible without the huge effort
deployed by our staff and various teams
uh in the committee is and in our MEP
offices the Ukraine facility will help
with rebuilding
reene Ukraine and enabling it to join
the European Union it it sets ambitious
goals we will work together with Ukraine
on a common European future to allow
Ukraine to rebuild its country it needs
to table a Ukraine plan a master plan
this will be prepared
by the
government together with regional
authorities and Civil
Society the ultimate say on the plan in
Ukraine will go to the vova rad the
Ukrainian
Parliament extensive rebuilding and
modernizing of Ukraine cannot um be
achieved through public coffers alone we
also need to see grants
and investment by the private sector we
need to get that investment to Ukraine
sooner than one might expect in war
times and so we want to ensure support
for Ukrainian
smes honorable members ladies and
gentlemen 50 billion Euro that is a huge
sum of M money a real show of solidarity
from the European Union we will look at
security measures and we will take
safeguards to prevent corruption and
misuse of funds we are demanding
transparency and scrutiny and have made
proposals to ensure those ends it is
encouraging and it makes
sense to ensure that Civil Society
organizations in Ukraine are involved
they will carry out monitoring work
where State and European structures are
overwhelmed Ukraine already has
extensive
experience through the partnership
principle ladies and gentlemen it is
extremely important that Ukraine not
just wins the war but also strengthens
democracy at all levels to ensure
prosperity for its citizens with the
help of the European Union Slava Ukraine
colleag G
nextal Ru please the floor is
yours thank you president commissioner
colleagues since the outset of the
Russian aggression on Ukraine we have
been mobilizing funds to support
politically economically and socially
Ukraine and this facility is a priority
that is why it is necessary in urgent
for us to proove this new mechanism for
50 billion in Grants and Loans now the
Russian AGG aggression against Ukraine
has caused economic damage multi-million
in damage and when it comes to the
public revenues necessary to stand up to
this aggression and to maintain the
services we've seen an enormous increase
now you would agree then that the
Russians would pay to for the damages
caused to Ukraine and that is why we are
requesting that the commission establish
a legal basis along with other
institutions to be able to confiscate
the Russian assets for the purposes of
reconstruction and to compensate the
victims of the aggression all of that
that has been con uh confiscated would
be then used through this facility that
we are discussing a facility that will
include a number of different support
programs with a better coherence and
consistency we are giving a predictable
instrument to Ukraine to be able to
maintain its public services and assist
in the rebuilding and modernization of
the country we will also be supporting a
reform plan for Ukraine and it on its
path to the EU along with civil society
and local
authorities a plan must be established
that would then be uh adopted this plan
much like the
rrf will have a long and detailed list
of reforms and Investments with specific
milestones and dates the objective is
also to invest in the Ukrainian economy
making sure that it is digital green and
in integrated now this means that people
will have dignified living conditions in
the country critical infrastructure will
be established and will be able to make
sure that there are good jobs in the
future it is clear that there are major
challenges that Ukraine will face to be
able to uh move on its path to EU
accession this facility is a is a step
in that direction Ukraine of course
needs to shore up its rule of law and
its uh law enforcement fighting corrup
corruption corruption and fighting
organized crime and oligarchs it must
fight money laundering as well
as tax evasion and avoidance as well as
access to information rebuilding is a
long-term objective it's extremely
ambitious and at the time we don't know
exactly what it will require but what we
do need to be able to do is Count both
on the private and the public uh sector
as well as in uh internet institutions
member states as well as the European
Investment Bank we would like to have a
specific pillar that will be uh set
aside for the coordination of all of
these players with strong attention
being paid to small and mediumsized
corporations finally the facility has
another pillar that will mean that we
will give technical support to the
townships and to Civil Society much like
what took place during the rrf during
the
pandemic what the EU needs to be able to
do is not just support Ukraine
economically but do this through a
consistent instrument that is flexible
and with specific investments in
uh modernization as well as reform in
the medium and the long term so now here
we are and we hope that we will be able
to negotiate with Council as quickly as
possible so that this will take uh force
in 2024 thank you very much Miss gas uh
Gia saal Ral and we continue with the
commission with commissioner Johannes
Han yeah for it's in
the this house for the sense of
importance and urgency that it has shown
in finding swiftly position on the
Ukraine facility the union has been
consistent in its support to Ukraine
since the beginning of Russia's war of
aggression so far together with our
member states we have provided more than
80 billion Euro through humanitarian Aid
economic and Military assistance as well
as support for ukrainians who have
sought refuge in the union the U is
committed to continue supporting Ukraine
for as long as it takes this is why as
part of the revision of the 's
multi-annual financial framework we have
proposed a new 50 billion Euro Ukraine
facility aimed at ensuring predictable
medium-term support for the country's
recovery and reconstruction the facility
will be closely tied to key reforms that
Ukraine needs to implement on its EU
accession track support under the
facility will be based on Ukraine's
fulfillment of conditions the facility
has been designed to enable the union to
provide different forms of support to
Ukraine while ensuring the necessary
flexibility to respond to the
circumstances on the ground as they
might evolve the government of Ukraine
will need to prepare a plan for Recovery
reconstruction and
modernization detailing the reforms and
Investments it intends to undertake
which also needed as part of its EU
accession process to ensure
predictability of funding support under
the facility will be provided in line
with the progress Ukraine will make in
delivering on this plan we already
working with Ukraine to facilitate
preparing the plan it's important that
the support from Key donors to Ukraine
remains well coordinated and coherent
only so can it be used to the maximum
since January this year we are engaging
with key donors through the G7 multi
agency donor coordination platform we
are encouraging other donors to use the
future plan
as a reference point in providing their
assistance our proposed Ukraine facility
also includes a robust framework for
transparency audit and control to ensure
the protection of EU Financial interests
a dedicated audit board consisting of
independent members appointed by the
commission will assist the commission by
reporting on the possible mismanagement
of the fund spent to achieve the
objective of the facility and by making
recommendations to
Ukraine honorable members the war
continues and Ukraine need support in
the form of fresh funding support that
will not risk adding to the country's
depth burden support to get its economy
on track so that in the longer run it
will be less dependent on donors and can
increasingly stand on its own feet
support to crowd in private investment
and support to keep Ukraine firm firmly
on its accession track with consistent
progress on reforms the commission is
grateful to the European Parliament and
in particular to the two Co
co-rapporteur for the speed with which
they have advanced on the draft report
that will be voted uh understand
tomorrow it's crucial to reach an
agreement before the end of this year to
ensure that Ukraine can continue to
receive our support already at the
beginning of next year so we hope that
the council will also proceed swiftly so
that trialogues could start as soon as
possible the commission will continue to
play its role to ensure that the next
steps of the negotiations deliver a
balanced and ambitious instrument that
can signal the Union's steadfast support
for Ukraine thank
you thank you very much Mr commissioner
and we continue with Mr Petri sarama
please
thank you chair honorable commissioner
dear
colleagues almost 600 days ago Russia
launched a brutal and murderous attack
against the sovereign state of Ukraine
since the very first day of this
cold-hearted attack the European Union
has stood by the side of Ukraine
providing 30 billion EUR from the EU
budget in support so
far the Ukraine facility will continue
this support it will ensure continuity
and predictability of the support for
the next three
years 50 billion euros is a reasonable
start for rebuilding Ukraine but we all
know that we will need more in the
future the economic costs of the Russian
attack are already now around2 70
billion EUR and the process of
rebuilding Ukraine has been estimated to
cost around 384 billion EUR and in
addition the psychological toll on the
Ukraine people will be
immeasurable it is of high importance
that the facility paves the way for
Ukraine to become a member of the
European Union endorsing the rule of law
as well as other fundamental European
values will create a steady foundation
for a strong Ukraine it will finally
allow for Ukraine's complete separation
from the Russian influence when
implementing the Ukraine facility the
European Union and Ukraine must ensure
that the funds end up with correct
beneficiaries there must be zero
tolerance for misuse of EU funds this is
of high importance in order to maintain
the legitimacy of the Ukraine support in
the eyes of EU citizens
but as long as this principle is
respected Ukraine can rest assured that
the European Union stands by its side as
long as it takes thank you thank you
very much Mr sarama and we continue with
Mr W chimic
please president
commissioner uh long-term aid for you
Ukraine is of absolute importance I
think that the proposal of the European
commission is a good starting point we
have enrich the starting point through
debates in the European Parliament and I
hope our position will be welcomed by
other EU institutions we want to support
day-to-day budget needs recovery
reconstruction of the of Ukraine we are
going to earmark for this quite a lot of
money but we have to realize that the
current budget gaps in Ukraine are huge
and that's why most of the money will
probably end up there soon Ukraine will
not be able to draw any more loans with
instit International institutions that
means that financing of uh re rebuilding
will just be illusionary in this context
we really have to uh
Define what we need to do first and that
would be uh confiscating the Frozen
Russian assets saying that we can't do
this legally is not
true at the moment we have no immunities
to deal with the parliament has already
put this forward forward as a proposal
and I definitely recommend this solution
to the
council the crimes the war crimes that
happened justifi that I understand that
some heads of state are against due to
some legal legal expertises that maybe
are not fully Justified or maybe for
business reasons but I would like to
remind you that Russia has already
gained um tens of millions of Euros
through various business deals with
Europe so uh let's not give up on this m
Mr petas aich
please
German commissioner ukrainians
colleagues today we are commemorating
600 days since the Russian invasion into
Ukraine since the infrastructure has
been damaged civilians have been killed
and various War atrocities have been
carried out the Russian war against
Ukraine is uh and its price is very huge
so we will need decades to rebuild the
country and its
economy the eu's decision to uh draw a
long-term plan for 24 27 and to have
this uh 50 billion facility is a very uh
very useful step I think it shows our
solidarity towards
Ukraine and it is a very concrete and
real action that we can show I think it
is important to us all that this
Ukrainian facility could help modernize
the economy of the country would also
increase the effectiveness of economy
and would also help increase the income
of its citizens I would also like to say
that verhovna in Ukraine uh must also uh
show its
responsibility uh in uptaking this
support we must also include social
Partners in the
process the Ukraine facility is a really
great great example of the partnership
of a Way
Forward restoring the Ukrainian economic
potential can be the best symbol of
Russian loss thank
you
andola
Viola go
ahead president president commissioner
honorable members as someone rightly
said Russia is a petrol station
pretending to be a supermarket we were
fooled by the myth of Russia as military
power for 600 days now ukrainians have
defended their uh country against
Putin's
War it has defended its access to the
sea to allow wheat to be and grain to be
exported Ukraine is Def defending its
own freedom of course but also our
freedom in the European Union and every
said we invest in Ukraine is money that
we invest in democracy and our security
the new Ukraine facility 50 billion Euro
will help ukrainians to survive and to
rebuild their country a country that can
become better and Greener an example for
all others we are guaranteeing a future
for ukrainians decided by their people
their Parliament their Civil Society
their local authorities they will decide
what the Ukraine of the future will look
like European taxpayers however need to
know how their monies are being spent
and so we have ensured that there will
be comprehensive transparency attached
to the Ukraine facility we can ensure
therefore that every scent that is
invested in the country will be
accounted for this is to help Ukraine
join the European Union there is a real
uh example here of rebuilding recovery
and reform we will see a more democratic
Ukraine a Green Engine powering the
future of Europe thank you and my thanks
to both reporters for the excellent
cooperation thank you very much we'll
continue with Mr
bdan thank you very much uh president
uh commissioner I live quite closely to
the border with the Ukraine so I'm very
much aware of what is
going um on and yes we do support every
possible action that is supposed to help
Ukraine and yes the place of Ukraine is
in the EU this is quite evident however
we don't want to multiply all kinds of
requirements that have to be met uh by
the Ukraine for example in terms of The
Greening of the requirements what these
people need is a job uh good labor
market
uh just conditions to survive and
prosper uh the time for fighting
corruption will come of course the
Ukraine if it wants to join the EU will
have to face the problem of corruption
the money that we are offering them now
is a lot it's 50 billion Europe yes
that's true uh we are talking about both
uh grants and uh
subsidies uh I'm sure uh we will if we
offer them loans they will not be able
to pay them back so this will have to be
uh grants uh that is why my group wants
uh to first of all analyze profoundly
what the real needs are and uh uh take
do a stock taking of what we have
already proved provided for and where it
ended up it is very difficult for the
Ukraine to sustain this this pace of uh
uh progress uh they are still fighting
they are fighting for our freedom as
well and we have to uh support them I
would also like
to appeal to you to uh not pay attention
to fake news uh for example in Poland um
we had election
yesterday and Mr verber said here in
this room that Donald Tusk won the
election that is not true this is fake
news the Civic platform only got
28% it's the law and Justice party uh
that got for the time being
38% and Counting so if Mr verber knows
his algebra uh should
do well to to check it up we'll begin
with uh we'll continue with Mr
marani thank you 70 billion EUR is what
you are requesting between 2024
2027 for Ukraine 70 billion in addition
to the 72 billion that have already been
earmarked by the EU since 2022
commissioner now I'm not even talking
about the 400 billion that are being
requested for future rebuilding that is
a lot of money our fellow citizens will
be looking at us because of the increase
in interest rates and inflation and the
these uh funds will be given without
any sort of uh counterpart as the was
stated of on the 5th of October by the
court of Auditors if we look at the
budget about 10% in 2023 because of
inflation will uh this These funds will
be increased and that will actually
weaken weaken any future European
budgets now these funds are G be being
given to a corrupt political class all
the way up to the top even to the
president and that is precisely what we
are trying to do for Ukraine nothing
more nothing less mer and we thank you
very much Mr MC Wallace please the floor
is yours yeah
commissioner the 50 billion Ukraine for
is a rushed inadequate mechanism tailor
made for corruption and embezzlement of
EU funds on a massive scale there are
simply not enough measures in the
proposal to mitigate the threats posed
by the rampant high level corruption in
Ukraine Ukraine is to courot John CLA
junker corrupt at all levels of society
read any European Court of Auditors
report on Ukraine and find similar
conclusions they document a complete
lack of value for money in terms of
reforms and progress achieved with the
EU funds is constantly under threat in
their opinion on the facility they say
the proposal fails to demonstrate how
the risk will be
mitigated oligarchs and vested interests
across Ukraine are the root cause of
corruption and obstacle to economic
development in the country the facility
has no provision to exclude companies
under oligarch influence from receiving
support we are constructing a colonial
debt trap for Ukraine facilitating more
destruction as we continue to fuel the
war and further theft of lands and ass
by Western
Capital I'm in favor of helping Ukraine
but you are not going to help them with
more debt two-thirds of the money is
debt you're going to kill them with that
how are they going to pay it back they
won't pay it back in the next 50 years
but what a will mean is that we're
colonizing the place it's bad enough we
have Western companies now they have
bought up uh more land and a fire sale
price that the Russians have taken on
the east side what's around with us we
are we're going to take their land and
we're going to take their workers for
cheap labor for Western European
countries we're going to poize the place
we're creating a bleak future for the
people of
Ukraine thank you next speaker is Mr
Fabio masimo castaldo please the floor
is
yours thank
you chair commissioner colleagues
firstly I'd like to thank the reporters
for the great work that they've done and
tomorrow once again we will confirm our
support to the people of Ukraine today
we've got an important Mission um in uh
ke
um I've been there myself and I saw if
what's happened in the last uh few
months and the um terrible damage that
has been dealt out for uh
Ukraine they're fighting for their
freedom and reconstruction is going to
be incredibly difficult but it is
nonetheless a moral imperative we have
to ensure that we um are not ambiguous
here and that we not we do not operate
under jeel standards we have to uh face
up to the reality of this
situation we also have to uh place the
blame where it's due with the regime of
Vladimir
Putin we have to stand up to our
commitments we need to ensure that with
this instrument we are confirming um
democracy and the rule of law Ukraine
will never be a brutalized part of the
Russian imperialist regime slav ukraina
uh Casto and we continue with Miss
Sandra canet
please president commissioner colleagues
the place of Ukraine is in Europe the
courageous Ukrainian have demonstrated
this for the second year already they
have paid their lives it's a very high
price therefore we have to make this
decision today the decision on accession
and we should start the procedure next
uh year so that Ukraine can become in
the next decade member of the EU uh we
support this Ukrainian facility in the
amount of 50 billion for the time period
from 24 to 27 this is meant for support
to reconstruction uh renovation and
implementation of the reforms necessary
to join the EU we should come to the
agreement on this mechanism as soon as
possible in order to approve it together
with the budget for the next year
therefore we should amend the
multiannual framework from
2127 and we
need unanimous voting in the council for
that it is very important to show
support and to continue showing support
to Ukraine starting from the next year
in this instrument we should not include
the repayment of credit and we should
also not take into account the the the
foreign assets that will become
available when when Russia assets are
seized this mechanism should be flexible
it should allow taking very rapid and
needed decisions and it should be very
absolutely transparent here is our
colleague Margarita markes please floor
is
yours thank you very much president
commissioner since the outset of the war
the European Parliament has defended and
voted in favor of financial support for
Ukraine now we again support the
European commission's proposal for a
medium and long-term financing solution
to continue to support Ukraine now this
is a solution that is within the union
budget it is based not just on loans but
also on
grants now this is a solution that means
that we need a review of multi Financial
framework re uh revision it is necessary
and Urgent this solution is capable of
leveraging other International donors
and mobilizing more support for Ukraine
in a world experiencing increasing
conflict on the do global scale it is
necessary to do this to continue
financing Ukraine because on the TW on
the 31st of December financing to
Ukraine will cease but also to mitigate
the impact of the war on the lives of
Europeans
and to uh create budgetary space for new
challenges that aren't actually new
challenges as they are old challenges
that have been come urgent yet again in
this current Global geopolitical
context
for some time now I've been hearing in
Brussels and Strasburg that the European
Union has grown tired of helping Ukraine
luckily the ukrainians are not tired of
fighting luckily the ukrainians are not
tired of dying at our borders luckily
they are not tired of stopping Russia's
missiles before they reach Romania
Poland or Estonia luckily the Romanians
are not tired of taking shelter night
after night from the Russian drones that
cross the border orders luckily the
European citizens are not tired of
helping mothers and children fleeing
with only their clothes on from the rape
torture and death spread by Putin How
can we become tired when others are
fighting and dying but yes indeed
something must change we must start to
truly respect European citizens we must
not allow ourselves to continue to spend
European money for Ukraine when the
hundreds of billions of Euros of the
oligarchs and of the Kremlin regime are
just lying there we can no longer
protect Putin's accomplishes uh fortunes
we can no longer Finance um the business
partners of uh Putin in Europe whether
uh they are European companies or not we
can no longer encourage Putin's friends
blackmail in the European Union we can
no longer tolerate the avoidance of
sanctions and exemptions from exemptions
60 days of Wars have passed for the
peace and prosperity of European
citizens we have a duty to support
Ukraine's fight and its reconstruction
but using the the money of its attackers
using the money of those responsible for
the destruction of whole cities using
the money of those polluting our air
water and soil using the money of those
Burning uh the grains in order to raise
our prices using the money of those that
thought they would bring Europe to its
knees with propaganda and gas from the
money of Vladimir Putin and its
oligarchs take their money next isaman
the next speaker is Mr Damian
Baga
thank you chair commissioner colleagues
um the Ukraine facility is a sign of
historic support for Ukraine and I'm
proud to be part of the negotiation team
it's historic because we sent two strong
messages the first one is that our
commitment to Ukraine is long and
longterm the Ukraine facility is an
Institutional design for a long-term
tool that is why it's so important not
only how much we spend but also how we
spend the money and I'm happy that some
of our ideas were taken up here
especially when it comes to defining a
minimum share fores because we do need
um Ukraine to build new businesses
introduce Innovations and push forward
the green transition instead of just
pouring helicopter money on state-owned
Enterprises and the second important
message and I think that's also key to
underline is good institutions matter
we've learned from the Marshal fund that
good governance checks and balances and
transparency matter especially in a
country that hopefully sooner rather
than later will join the EU we have
therefore strengthened institutions such
as the Rada fofa we have involved local
actors civil society and we ask for a
list of final beneficiaries to be able
to follow the money colleagues I also
want to say that reconstruction will
need many additional funds let's face it
50 billion over four years will not be
sufficient to support Ukraine until the
end of the war and for the
Reconstruction but we started by setting
this program up long term and I'm happy
that we do that because in the end I
mean some colleagues and I we went to
Ukraine recently what ukrainians
enduring for democracy is uh is really
hard and I think giving some support
here is the least we can do thank you so
much thank you very much Mr Baga next
speaker is Mr Johan van ELD
please for commiss president
commissioner honorable members since
February 2022 Ukraine has been fighting
a war against an evil power that
represents a threat in every sense for
our Western values there can be no doubt
that Ukraine deserves our full support
in this fight against barbaric
oppression in defense of Freedom our
commitment initially came in the shape
of support for the
Army it became clear at that point that
we in the European Union need to
thoroughly overhaul a fure future proof
defense spending we also showed our
responsibility towards Ukrainian Society
the EU would like to play an important
role in the recovery reconstruction and
modernization of Ukraine through uh by
supporting investment the investment
that the country needs to rebuild our
commitment is clear but we should not
ignore the fact that uh unfortunately in
Ukraine there is still a risk of
corruption we need to ensure sufficient
audit and checks such as an audit board
I would call for transparency and proper
Democratic scrutiny through this
Parliament thank you very much
Mr and we'll continue with
ryer the eu's policy on Politics on um
uh Ukraine has uh fallen short they're
not effective and they're
counterproductive
even everything seems to be uh
stagnating if not completely failing
here and when politics fails us we need
to have a rethink but in the EU it seems
that the opposite is happening instead
pouring a further 50 billion euro into
Ukraine into an incredibly corrupt
country and Ukraine is corrupt across
the board that's something that
jeanclaude Yuna said himself across
across the board at all levels
and Ukraine has got um so many
corruption scandals it is throughout all
of its um organizations and um in all of
its um
Ministries the European Court of
Auditors said that
um money sending money to places that
are corrupt simply will not help and now
we're talking about sending 50 billion
Euro further over there with no real
controls 50 billion Euro which is going
to be available to uh corrupt
politicians and really I have to ask
what is going on at the commission now
here this
is people who you want to send 50
billion EUR to a country which is
entirely corrupt that's not going to
help anyone
yeser Mr Haider we've got a blue card
from yeah miss m
please
collea okay this is noted as
yeah we continue now we continue then um
with um vice president papad diulus
diit thank you ch
Ukraine uh needs to be rebuilt and they
also need our
solidarity and with this report the
European Parliament not only supports
but also improves upon the commission's
proposal a proposal that will give this
country uh 50 billion EUR in loans and
guarantees but in order to be able to
rebuild Ukraine the first thing we need
is for the war to stop
Putin's Invasion has to stop otherwise
we cannot rebuild and there is the point
where the commission the European Union
has to do more because it's been two
years since the invasion and while the
war is going on we cannot have uh any
kind of
rebuilding and we need to fight
corruption there's this orgy of
corruption taking place in the Ukraine
right now and unless we do something
about
it we do something with Deeds not words
then that money is going to disappear in
a black hole and it will go into the
pockets of the oligarchs and not the
Ukrainian people so we need transparency
as to where this money is going and this
is where the European Parliament wants
certain taxs and balances and we hope
that the council with the help of the
commission will accept accept those
proposal Fernandes
please thank you very much president
colleagues
commissioner it is Our obligation to
defend Liberty the rule of law democracy
Freedom Light and H life and human
dignity and that is why we support
Ukraine this is precisely why we must
continue to support these values and
support Ukraine by doing that we are
defending the citizens of the EU it is a
urgent for the council to decide to
review at the
mff such that we can make this support
possible because we know that the
programming ends this year the current
budget doesn't have a margin it has no
flexibility to be able to continue to
offer this support in the negotiations
for the mff we stated the fact that the
budget wasn't enough that there wasn't
enough flexibility and that we wanted to
be able to be up to the challenge of
what is happening today but to what
might take place in the future to
unforeseen or unpredictable event uh
events therefore we need a revision of
that budget we are looking at through
this facility of Grants and
Loans but we have to keep in mind that
the costs of this support is going to be
much higher and that is why we need this
revision I would like to call therefore
on the council to act and to act
urgently such that they uh adopt the uh
mff for the purposes of this objective
this is an obligation that we have
obligation that is to continue to
support Ukraine thank you continue with
Mr taon
please dear president commissioner
colleagues with everything we did so far
in support of Ukraine there was always
one certainty we need to do more but
this is a great proposal it structures
and reinforces our support to Ukraine
and it will serve as a blueprint for
followup schemes the impact of this
support for the reforms and the
restructuring undertaken while fighting
the Russian aggression can't be
underestimated precisely because there
is still a lot to do we will keep we
will help Ukraine until victory until
ready to join the EU but as I said we
need to do more and this facility would
be even more meaningful if we would stop
incr incre incrementalism and deliver
more weapons faster Santi eams speed up
Pilots training and senta jets bring on
the 12th sanction package including
diamonds and Russian LNG and enforce the
sanctions Ukraine must win as fast as
possible thank you very much Mr Reon and
we continue with our colleague Miss
Hilda vaans
please
thank you thank you president
commissioner honorable members Victor
Hugo once
said that the dark night will end at
some point and the sun will rise now
ukrainians are experiencing a dark night
but it will end and we are showing here
that we will offer our support to
Ukraine to rebuild its country we've
guaranteed that support through to
2027 of course we need to scrutinize
that
support we need to look at harnessing
any Frozen Russian Assets in Europe to
this end our prime minister in Belgium
last week took a first step in that
direction Europe needs to take a leaf
out of Mr tru's book we want Ukraine to
win the war it needs military support we
need to keep up the pressure on Putin we
cannot imagine what would happen if
Putin were to win this war colleagues
we've taken a step in the right
direction but we need to do more we need
to flesh out the defense union we need
to ensure a real European Defense uh
industry and Supply weapons and then we
can put an end to the dark night thank
you thank you Bernard simak is our next
speaker
president president the current
situation in Ukraine um provides um
significant um um options for um people
such as Black
Rock
now the um aim of um investment uh
Society is the same as it is for
the
people Black Rock however it seems want
to profit from the situation in Ukraine
through
privatization and uh less options for
trade
unions the current legal situation is
going to open up um windows for people
who want to take advantage of it Ukraine
it seems is at risk of being for
sale and so we must act cautiously we
need to ensure that um the
um that the land is not fertile for such
um
actions the European
taxpayers with this 50 billion Euro um
are now to take on responsibility for
the um Ukrainian
citizens it seems like the Ukrainian an
elite and no one else is going to be the
winner here we have to look at what
hides behind this war and we don't want
to H end up um the prey of um this war
instead we need to try to support
Ukrainian citizens here with our
colleague Mr andreus kubilius
please dear
colleagues today we are discussing one
of the most important European Union
geopolitical initiatives I can just
congratulate Commission on the proposal
to establish Ukraine facility and to
allocate 50 billion EUR for the period
of 20124
2027 but as commission put into
explanatory note there will be a need of
384 billion EUR during the next 10 years
that is why facility with a 50 billion
euros is just the beginning we need to
see from where and when additional
Financial Resources will come and it's
time to make make a bold decision on
counter measures and to confiscate all
the 300 billion EUR of Frozen Russian
Assets in addition we need to be very
clear with the establishment of needed
institutional architecture for the whole
almost half a trillion EUR
reconstruction plan from my point of
view because of geopolitical
significance of the whole reconstruction
there is a need of for a special
dedicated EU agency like it was done
with EU Agency for rec construction of
Western Balkans also there is a need of
special high level EU Envoy for a
construction like Americans did with
appointment of secretary pritzker for
such a task I see also a need of more
clear IAS 3 Type framework in the
facility since it is declared that this
facility also will replace IA instrument
now we need to approve 50 billion
instrument but looking into the future
we need more more money and more
effective institutional Arrangement on
EU
side thank you very much Mr kubilius
next speaker is Mr ero
please thank you very much the suffering
of the Ukrainian people is something
that is impossible to understand in
Europe of the 2st
century
Russia militarily in invades the country
therefore we have to provide all
support financial support to Aid Ukraine
to reestablish the sovereignty of this
country and to make sure that there is
peace and reconstruction of the country
when it comes to this facility to the
tune of 50 billion the European
Parliament should support it
wholeheartedly moreover we we should
State extremely clearly that Russia
should offer economic
support for all of the destruction that
it is wre now we need to continue to
support ukraini the ukrainians and we
shouldn't accept any corruption
therefore we need to support continue to
show that we we'll stand with
Ukraine M thank you president
commissioner honorable
members with all eyes legitimately
focused on the Middle East Vladimir
Putin is rubbing his hands in Glee
stepping up attacks and continuing to
commit heinous
crimes we have earmarked 50 billion for
Ukraine and it is urgently needed coming
at a time when the US is no longer able
to guar guarantee to offer funding
guarantees it is also a healthy reminder
it demonstrates whose side we're on the
side of democracy of powerful values
peace freedom rule of law pluralism in
short everything that Vladimir Putin and
some of his fans on the far right and
far left have scorned through their past
votes in this chamber this European Aid
will not only offer long-term support to
help you ukrainians rebuild their
country ensure working hospitals and
schools it will ensure that the schools
can continue to educate children that
have been traumatized by
bombardments it is also European Aid to
protect 40 million facing uh belligerent
nationalism thank youand thank you very
much now Lucas Mandel thank
you thank you president commissioner
colleagues the European commission is
having to deal with a lot of criticism
um in recent times um citizens who are
turning to their European Parliament and
demanding a lot and that's quite right
but the Ukraine facility the
reconstruction plan for Ukraine is
something for which the commission
should get a lot of
Praise what's being done here is so
important that we need to take action
now and prepare now for the
Reconstruction of Ukraine 50 billion is
going to be um handed over and that is
going to be good for all of us in Europe
for us as well as Ukraine it's important
that we are giving the grants and Loans
but it's also important that we've got
the investment programs that are going
to be set up with the private sector and
third parties the so-called technical
Aid which is also such great support for
for a psychological reconstruction as
well to help the victims of war and
those traumatized by the
war this is something which has to be
successful in Ukraine the population is
going to be
traumatized it's going to be incredibly
important to help them uh get their
infrastructure back on its
feet a lot of companies European
companies Austrian companies are working
together um with Ukraine and for
Ukrainian citizens and I'm absolutely
delighted that all of this is also being
done under the leadership of an Austrian
commissioner Mr Han and we continue with
vice president P pno
please thank you thank you president
commissioner
colleagues for a year and a half now
European uh Ukrainian citizens
have forgotten what it means
normality what a daily life is like
because the Russian terrorist attacks
have a huge cost for the citizens bombs
mines
landmines all of this is destroying
schools roads hospitals and it means
that people do not have access to basic
services and it denies them the ability
to look to the future with faith
therefore we need to assist Ukraine to
stand up again to work together for a
world of future based in
trust this facility should be for solid
reforms for a European future for Kiev
to give longlasting support to Ukraine
even using Russian confiscated assets
because there will not be any peace
without Justice a free and solid and
Democratic Ukraine also means that we
need to uh that will mean that Europe
will be a prosperous and stable
place thank you Mr Vice President dear
colleagues Russian aggression against
Ukraine has lasted not for two but
already 10 years the full scale attack
began 600 days ago Defenders of Ukraine
have heroically confronted Russian war
machine by defending its ownland the
Ukraine people defend our values our way
of life that Russia is trying to
demolish countless Ukrainian lives have
been lost in this
war the EU and West can help Ukraine and
its people to defend their home we must
continue providing military supp support
there is no space for war fatigue it is
an important to help Ukraine with
reconstruction and reform efforts it's
absolutely vital that we endorse the
Ukrainian Ukraine facility package fast
the Ukraine facility must become the
modern day Marshall Plan for Ukraine it
should help Ukraine to utilize the
economic potential Ukraine is land of
opportunities with an immense industrial
and agricultural po potential
International Community must pursue the
possibility to use the Frozen funds of
Putin Russia for Ukraine's
reconstruction efforts it's obvious that
Ukraine facili 50 billion is not enough
but it is a good start uh good to start
a large scale reconstruction and reform
process thank you Slava
Ukraine thank you very much Mr teras and
we continue with Mr mik Bela
please
Mr chairman
commissioner the creation of the Ukraine
facility is a strong commitment from the
EU which shows that we will not abandon
Ukraine and will work towards its
Victory and EU
integration the 50 billion Euro package
has to support a build back better
principle and a set of strategic
projects to create a green sustainable
and just Ukrainian economy massive
public and private funding will be
needed to restore critical
infrastructure housing and repair
damages however the aggressor has to pay
we need to use Russia's frozen assets to
cover inflicted
damages the Reconstruction has to be
connected to EU accession our Ukrainian
friends have to work hard to implement
necessary reforms when this happens we
shall all meet in the EU as partners
thank you thank you very much Mr Bela
next speak is Madame mova
please
thank thank you uh chairman commissioner
dear
colleagues Ukraine uh has been defending
itself or 600 days against massive
Russian aggression and we know that
without assistance from the EU and other
allies is would not have been possible
which is why we uh need to continue to
provide uh military assistance weapons
but also uh we need to help with the
Reconstruction of the infrastructure
which is why I welcome this uh Ukraine
facility and I also welcome uh the fact
that uh it calls uh for a plan to
distribute this um assistance in
cooperation with the Ukrainian
government and I also think it's correct
that it should be under Democratic
control of the
ver that should monitor that the
assistant goes where it's
needed I also uh welcome the decision of
the competent Committee in the sense
that
um uh the assistant should go also for
hospitals sculture establishments
educational uh
centers and also uh centers for children
with our parents um or children that
need foster
care what is also important is that
Russia Bears
responsibility and also the costs of
this reconstruction and therefore we
need to use the confiscated assets of
the Russian uh regime and they need to
be used in this uh sense that next
speaker
is the next speaker is um Miss Karina
Olson
please
than thank
you this unprovoked and illegal war of
aggression on the part of Russia has
brought with this appalling suffering
for the Ukrainian people it is vital
that we continue to support the
Ukrainian people in their fight against
Russian aggression we need to continue
pressure on Russia to put an end to this
unjustified War a report has been
published on sexual abuse of Ukrainian
women and girls abuse carried out by
Russian
soldiers we also need to consider what
will happen when those soldiers return
home we know that violence triggers
further violence often as a result of
patriarchal
structures it is vital that in the
Ukraine facility we factor in gender
equality that must be reflected in any
future plan adopted by Ukraine we must
ensure gender
equality strengthen women's rights girls
rights the future of Ukraine is in the
European Union and that needs to be a
future that represents equality thank
you the floor and I invite Miss CLA Dy
to speak please thanks very much
president there's no doubt about it
reconstruction of Ukraine must be dealt
with and the European Union which hasn't
lifted a finger to work for peace but
has done everything to keep the war
going certainly has a role in that but I
think the question is how and why and if
you read the European Court of Auditors
report on this in accountant language
it's the equivalent of them jumping up
and down screaming blue murar that this
plan isn't T out it's an opportunity for
massive enrichment of a tiny minority of
both Russia uh Ukrainian oligarchs and
transnational Financial Corporation
ations in a country Infamous for
corruption if you think about it on the
one hand we're given 50 billion to
Ukraine in reconstruction in loans which
will never be repaid but will hang over
the population at the same time as we're
putting 20 billion to keep the
destruction going in arms and it make
you think is this some sort of a scam
and then you see the8 billion in
Insurance to guarantee the investors now
we had something like this in Ireland
years ago when Irish citizens bailed out
German Bond holders in vicious austerity
now it looks like the Ukrainian and
European citizens will be bailing out uh
bomb holders it's an absolute
joke I invite commissioner Han to take
the floor I at the
end I have to say listening to the last
speaker I think it's important to recall
that we are talking about an um war of
aggression of Russia of Putin's Russia
against Ukraine and uh I think it's it's
it's obvious that we as Europeans have
to support the ukrainians in order to
regain the territorial Integrity to help
citizens in Ukraine to survive and
that's why I am grateful for the
interventions today for the majority
huge majority of interventions today
which have send a strong message to
Ukraine and our International Partners
about our commitment to the recovery and
reconstruction of the country and for
placing Ukraine firmly on the path of
European accession and may I say and in
particular in these days where of course
for very understandable reasons our
focus is on uh the Middle East but we
should not forget what's going on in
Ukraine and therefore the people there
need our strong support in in terms of
uh moral support but also of course
financial support and that's why uh we
have to show uh the same dedication and
urgency um uh for for Ukraine also in
the future and thank you uh we can count
on both I have to say here the European
Parliament and the council to advance
quickly on their discussion so that uh
money can continue uh to be provided to
Ukraine uh next year here as well and
may I recall because I have heard today
several times talking about 50 billions
which are quasy transferred to Ukraine
uh these 50 billions are for the next
four years and they are split in a
compartment of 33 billions for a micro
financial assistance and 70 billions for
Grants part of it to serve the interests
stemming from the from the micro
financial assistance but also
anticipating future reconstruction
efforts and therefore to provide uh if
necessary and this is hopefully soon the
case uh provisions and guarantees for
financial institutions to provide the
necessary financial means in order to
support Ukraine's reconstructions as
fast as possible I think this instrument
uh which we are discussing today is
placing the Union at the Forefront of
all the international efforts for the
Recon construction and recovery of the
country and sending a strong signal
about ambitious and commitment and I
think this is equally important uh
looking at the situation in the United
States uh well it is not so sure if they
can continue supporting Ukraine at least
in the way they did it so far and
finally nevertheless I have to recall
that what we're talking today is part
and parcel of our mff midterm review so
we have to see that the entirety of the
review but of course the support for
Ukraine is the centerpiece of it thank
you very much thank you very much
commissioner Han we come back to the
reporters and I invite Mel Gala to take
the floor thank you very much first of
all to the large majority of of speakers
here thank you for reconfirming our
broad consensus I need to go into any
further details in this regard but I
would like to say to those who are
closest to Putin in this house they
really have no right to claim that is
corruption in Ukraine who is the
Godfather of Corruption of kleptocratic
structures that is Putin who wants with
his uh allies to regain control of this
country and rest assured that this
facility among other things will see to
it that there is a control of the
finances there is already
anti-corruption control working in
Ukraine Nabu zapo uh the proro system
for public procurement and there is the
political will of the real reformers and
and there is the the vigilance of the
Civil Society in Ukraine that we are
also including and strengthening here
and uh in so far I think this will be
one of the most controlled Financial
transactions that we have ever seen and
there was the other argument to say uh
we want to colonize uh uh with our
entrepreneurs Ukraine well the only one
who wants to colonize Ukraine is Putin
he is the slaveholder of his own country
and wants to establish his well even the
stalinist or fascist regime back in
Ukraine he will not succeed but I can
say something our investment in this
country make this country also safer
safer that has been the case in the
after War West Germany where there was
some arguments well there are so many
Americans and westerners coming and
buying things first of all nothing was
taken away the same will be the case in
Ukraine nobody takes anything away but
there will be a higher interest in this
country that it stays safe and on the on
the side of of freedom and democracy and
in so far I welcome all uh bigger and
smaller investors in Ukraine to uh to
contribute their share for the
Reconstruction of the country I think
that will be a good investment because
this country will at the end be an asset
to the European Union once again Slava
ukraini thank you very much and we will
conclude with Miss AER gabal rubial
please much thank you
president looking at the content of the
Ukraine facility I think we've said
everything we need to say it is a good
proposal from the commission and we in
the political groups have worked hard to
significantly improve the
facility I would like to use the minute
that I have left to thank in particular
my co- rapporter Mr Gala for the
excellent cooperation for his
availability his commit M to ensuring
that we strike an
agreement without that commitment and
work this proposal would not have um
been agreed we also appreciated the work
of all the
Shadows it's true that there are nuances
I don't think we have significant
differences of opinion but we have
different points of view and we managed
to resolve our differences all political
groups showed great Good Will to work
swiftly and to resolve any issues and
we've managed to come forward with this
Parliament proposal a plan to support
Ukraine that the Ukrainian government
it's local authorities and Civil
Society it will be fully fledged
participant both regions municipalities
will be involved so we have clear
commitments we have strict checks and
balances uh in place we really emphasize
the importance of scrutiny and I hope
that we will receive broad-based support
in this chamber it's very important that
we move swiftly on to negotiations with
Council so that this plan and this
regulation can enter into force on the
1st of January 2024 so that we can help
ukrainians and they need our full
support thank you very much very much
the debate is now closed and the vote
will be held tomorrow the next item on
the agenda is the report by Mr Fernandez
and Mr AER as